hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham finale video you know a lot
of crazy moments I think it's in a good
position for season 2 hopefully they'll
course-correct on some of the things
that didn't quite stick the landing but
I do think it did a couple things really
well this episode but just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with top 5 moments here we
go number 5 the penguin tries to kill
Falcone the mob war between Maroni and
Falcone has been going on for two weeks
and the penguin just been sitting on the
sidelines watching it all play out
penguin catches Falcone in a moment of
weakness but Gordon steps in it leads to
one of the oddest pairings that the show
has had but I think one of the most fun
ones Gordon is a character by himself
hasn't been super interesting I think he
works best when he's paired with the
crazier characters it's like when you
think about the characters and in the
context of a comedic duo it's like you
have a straight man that reacts to a
crazy person who tells all the jokes
Gordon not so great with the jokes
that's where the other characters come
in some of the pairings have been a
little odd but I think they can play
with that in season two they can start
pairing Gordon with other crazier
characters the more outlandish the best
and now that Barbara is full-on crazy
their scenes actually might be palatable
they just they didn't have any chemistry
on-screen and I love the way the show
has sidestepping them now on to number
four the city officials in Gotham back
moroni / Falcone so this is going to
play out more in season 2 the shady but
legitimate business people of Gotham
think that Maroni can do a better job of
keeping the peace than Falcone it's all
about the devil you know there were
several characters that entered into
situations like that Loeb is still
around he gave Gordon now told him to
hit the road so they're not outright
waging war on each other but I think
they're gonna deepen that relationship
in season 2 you'll see a lot more Gordon
versus the shadow elements in the city
people like the evil Wayne board
although that's kind of getting into
Bruce territory there's a lot of
different kinds of Batman villains you
have mob villains you have evil
businessmen villains and then you have
outright comic book villains raise your
hand if you think that Barbara turned
into a comic book villain in this
episode but on on to number 3 the
Catwoman drinks the kool-aid
there was this running plotline that I
think didn't quite land about characters
trying to overcome programming Catwoman
seemed like she got a little crazy she
seemed a little more in the driver's
seat than butch
and Barbara did that she was a little
more conscious of what she was doing but
I like the idea of fish Mooney taking
advantage of her offering her the
promise of a family in a home but
secretly twisting their relationship to
get Catwoman to do whatever she wants to
do taking advantage of her the same way
penguin takes advantage of butch maybe
some scenes got cut out but but we can
deal with it more in season two
Catwoman trying to figure out where she
belongs is she gonna be team Gordon is
she gonna be team penguin now now the
Penguins the king of crime we do have to
address that crazy warehouse crowd seen
when they walked in it's like all those
fish Mooney characters had spent the
past two weeks getting their hair and
makeup done
like they were getting ready to mount a
revival Broadway production of West Side
Story it's like yeah we're in the middle
of a war but we're going to accessorize
like we are going to be on stage this is
really where Gotham strays into campy
territory sometimes the show switches
tone and it seems a little uneven if you
remember way back in that Arkham episode
it opened with an actual stage play I
think sometimes the show tries to
visually invoke stuff like that and I
think it's a lot of fun but it needs to
be a little more consistent if it's
going to do that
Gotham is a little bit more open and
that it's campy and ridiculous at times
but sometimes it still feels like it
takes itself a little too seriously and
you can't really do that when you have
scenes like this when characters look
and talk like this in the in the set
looks like this - like how convenient is
it that they all have that bar there to
be strung up from so I'm not gonna
criticize that too much it just you know
it feels like they were going for almost
like a music video framing in terms of
the way they shot the scene but if
you're gonna do that then you kind of
need to do the whole season like that
visually the show needs to stay
consistent on to number two huge win for
Batman villains penguin dispenses with
fish Mooney in a very Batman Tim Burton
ace Chemical Joker type scene that was a
lot of fun weren't you just waiting for
that after the credits scene where the
hand rises out of the water the bad news
about that is the Jada Pinkett Smith
said that she only signed a contract for
one season so it sounds like they might
not be bringing her back in season two
but they're gonna be pushing the penguin
is the only big crime boss like they're
done with this big mob war stuff it
makes sense that they don't want to
rehash that from season one in season
two but nygma also almost goes full-on
Riddler I don't seem like he was
developing multiple personality
disorders the Riddler in the comic books
doesn't have mold
personality disorders he's very aware of
what he's doing I think they cut that
scene in a really trippy way just to
show you how he's like slowly descending
into madness but do not be fooled it's
not like he's gonna quit the police
station in between seasons he'll still
be in there he'll just start doing more
and more crazy stuff he's right on the
precipice of becoming the Riddler he
just needs to commit to it now and this
whole murder situation with Miss Kringle
is just like the thread that he's gonna
start pulling on that'll unravel him I
really think that he was trying to talk
himself into killing this Kringle like
trying to justify it in his head was
like well she's gonna find out so I got
to get rid of her as if an answer to the
rise of the Batman villains to you have
the rise of the Batcave so we'll go down
that staircase in season two and find
out whatever is down there it'll
probably just like a tiny version of the
Batcave
it's really hard to pinpoint like where
this show is in the timeline it looks
like it's in the 80s based on their car
technology based on the types of cars
they drive around so we might find some
computers down there probably just a
bunch of files and evidence that his
father was piecing together it was kind
of fun to see Bruce go into detective
mode you know Batman world's greatest
detective
now he's world's greatest detective in
training and finally my number one WTF
moment
Barbara goes completely Nutter Butter
that last scene where Leslie Thompkins
overpowers Barbara and is like smashing
her head on the floor and Gordon walks
in all of a sudden that was my my most
favorite moment all season long it was
so ridiculous so funny sometimes you can
tell with the shows gonna do based on
the way they frame shots so it's like
the minute the camera left all that open
space on this side of the frame you just
you knew that door was gonna open
regardless of what you thought of
Barbara's character this season I feel
like then taking her character in the
crazy Harley Quinn direction is the best
thing it could have done best possible
outcome you can use this to explain why
her character acted the way she did all
season long she felt like she was hollow
inside and now we find out that she
actually kind of is dead inside during
that whole conversation that was about
making her parents seem like terrible
people
I don't know if that was really
authentic given that we know Barbara's
crazy so she could have been you know
falsely remembering a lot of that stuff
I think the show was trying to be
authentic in that though like her
parents traumatized her in a
way as a child so it like slowly chipped
away at her and the ogre just kind of
pushed her over the edge
it's like in dark night where the Joker
pushes Harvey Dent over the edge and he
becomes two-face the ogre pushed Barbara
over the edge and she's turning into
kind of like a Harlequin character I
know there's a lot of questions about
which characters the show is allowed to
do they're probably not allowed to do
Harley Quinn so she's just going to be a
similar type character like she'll
probably head to Arkham that provides
hour into Arkham which allows us access
to like all the other crazies that they
might roll out like the other new
characters we might see in season 2 like
mr. freeze we know that he is coming on
the show although he's probably not
gonna come out of Arkham here's my big
question for you guys you know what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and how do you feel about what it did
with Barbara's character there's so many
things that I feel like the show did
wrong this season but that happens in a
lot of series first seasons that's
usually the time that the writers take
to get to know their characters
sometimes it just takes a while to find
voices it's like the way people talk
about the Simpsons Gudrun it's like the
first couple of seasons were kind of
weird good but weird but then it really
came into its own in its middle seasons
before it jumped the shark after like
seasons 8 & 9 so sometimes it just takes
a little while you know I think a good
example of a show that's done a really
good job from the start has been the
flash since we're entering the off
season and they're already starting to
work on season 2 what I'm probably to do
is transition to more movie videos but
I'll try and do some more Batman related
bonus videos you know especially like
you know mr. freeze characters that we
might see in season 2 if there's
anything specific you guys want just let
me know
and don't forget Grodd versus the flash
tonight be sure to subscribe to get that
video I'll post it after the episode
airs in case you guys haven't seen it I
actually did a breakdown of the trailer
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here for all my other Gotham
videos this season
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you